I do want to get to why you want to talk
here today it's important to me as well
actually my house manager my one of my
really good friends Ava we've been
talking about this because she's in LA
holding our house down for us and I'm
like don't go out cuz it's worse for
African Americans and and where are you
right now and how squinching going for
you though
quarantine is going good and you're
actually absolutely spot-on right Kelly
it's it's uh you know it's funny when
you start to think about the ratio and
population of black people we only make
up 13% which of course makes this
minority but it's 33% of Kovach patients
are african-american and some of them
were african-american because of course
you know the virus comes and it's so
many different types and I don't it's
just so mind-blowing but 13 that's a big
number 33 percent of patients are
african-american and we have to get that
number down and I don't know what's
making people feel like either it can't
happen to them whether they're an
African American community or not but
you have to take this seriously because
you know one thing happens like right
after another which is oh you go out
your friend has it your friend gives it
to you you give it to Grandma then I T
then this person then those people give
it to someone else that's how it's Frank
so fast and we just have to take this
way more seriously you got to think
about also the the illnesses from high
blood pressure high cholesterol
hypertension asthma so many different
illnesses that have been really
generational you know illnesses in the
african-american community yeah yeah so
you know is we just want to be smart
about all this and I just really want to
encourage everyone to stay inside we're
not quite done with this but we can be
if we really practice our social
distancing and have I'd like to say
kindness because when you actually
approach this with kindness then you'll
think about the fact that I don't want
this to happen to me and let me just be
kind stay in my home and be smart about
all of them
oh and be kind of other circulars like
maybe you have an okay immune system and
maybe you might be fine but first of all
I do love a level of invincibility
people think they're invincible like
they watch and they're like oh that
happens to someone else I'm like you
could be that someone else really
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going